[Music]
I'm pratika tautum I've been with Abbott
14 years my current role is leading
product development I'm a mom I'm a wife
I'm a colored female I'm in technology
space I'm sitting here in Stanford
campus
feeling uncomfortable but okay being
uncomfortable as I've grown organically
in the career I needed to create some
Frameworks that can pivot my career into
the next level my own leadership style
is evolving that's a huge Revelation for
me this is an area that I thought I was
already good at but I was like no no
there's a lot more to be done the reason
I chose SCP I was looking for specific
topics like design thinking or strategy
the diversity in the cohort that
attracted me I need to bring a lot of
different perspectives and and see how
those perspectives are also being
received SCP has already started giving
me a lot of tools and Frameworks it's
not just an executive program you become
part of the GSP Alum so it's a network
it's a family it's a connection that you
can continue to build on and give back
to I feel like I'm walking away with
lifelong friends
you know I'm so glad that I'm here and
I'm doing this